[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it
in cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
ohio state
[Laughter]
um space jams
jordan 11's size 11. now i gotta tell
white mike you're only betting
you cool yeah i don't know huh the only
time i bet is on uh sports
peep day's done
[Laughter]
i don't do chains yeah you don't do
chains that's not a chain i think that's
something location
pinks is pretty hot i think i think that
but i think that's the only location the
one in the mall but you [ __ ] no no
no no no no no that's what melrose is in
no no i haven't been there oh that
probably is there that's not a
look like a sneaker release yes yeah
this lines for that
right now probably nothing more a nice a
thick
bratwurst so if you was at a baseball
game you're getting a hot dog oh
a dodger dog all day mustard
diced onions sauerkraut that's your
trash i know
that's what do you do at the baseball
game
we had different answers you said he
watched
it
i've only been the one baseball game it
was in 2006
it was uh the diamond diamond diamond
blacks diamondbacks play uh
san francisco and it was uh uh homies
like last night
yeah it was like his last well that's
that's really what you going yeah
uh with some friends did you have fun
[ __ ] no i was bored the whole time
well you got to be dr but you were two
no no sticks
what are you doing then dude
oh see chappelle not getting loose at
the basement i wasn't 21 at the time who
gives a [ __ ] you don't have any friends
anybody drinks
sneak drinks into the game stinging some
drugs have something some drugs
yeah i don't do drugs i feel like you
you hang around with a lot of friends
that wear all black air forces
and i don't appreciate that yeah yeah
something in your life is different
yeah a baseball game bro sneak in
a drugs sporting event imagine you're on
molly and just like oh my god yeah
all right
you see that he's so crazy
this [ __ ] is talking like he's
going to a raven you don't sneak
in drugs to a baseball game hell no
talk to the hoes been to a baseball game
probably three years ago someone gave me
tickets or ca gave me tickets so i had
like the
dope seats i brought my girl oh okay
what was the last sporting event
like was that the last sporting event
you went to
you went to excellence i went to laker
hell no i went to a lakers game
again with c you don't [ __ ] with xfl
that's the reason why it's xfl
oh yeah the rock ones are now though
right yeah so they're bringing it back
no he's giving these [ __ ] a
chance no i didn't i'm probably
you guys are really hating on it i'm
pretty sure it's not gonna be a
smackdown yeah not for me
really not like that's a no for me are
they giving like
nfl players like
like chances to start that's a no no
legit nfl guy's gonna play in that well
didn't old boy from the xfl get drafted
uh
quarterback yeah yeah he was abusive
there's a quarterback that got drafted
look what it looked great you know what
he's doing he's a backup for he's not
playing
that's my point okay thank you guys for
[ __ ]
all right last night hey where the [ __ ]
is my jersey we better jersey
on the browns game you guys and this was
alarming you don't you guys you and jay
asked for a lamellar bulger
but he's he's balling this year yeah i
don't care he's kind of weird
where's jersey why because he's
20 years old well for one he's not 20 i
think he's 19.
even worse you can wear 19 the youngest
guy
you're going to rock a 19 year old's
jersey on the street the youngest guy
that ever recorded triple double you
know who was oh
yeah he's 19 years his brother so i'm
trying to tell you i support i love
greatness
yeah he'll be 20 this year still it's
hard to rock uh
you want a young kid's jersey you wanted
a kevin durant
few okay whatever you saw i'll call him
now now lamellar ball he's played
three games do you think lamelo's future
hall of fame of course that's
it that's it i see it in him do you
really bro he recorded he's balling
right now his rookie year
okay he's balling right now what's such
a long ways to go bro and he
he scored like 22 and he didn't find his
shot yet once he find that shot he
hasn't even found this
bro he has confidence if you haven't
found it yet you're never going to find
it here's the
only place yeah how's his brother doing
here's wait that's his brother he's
getting there
he beat his brother he's not going to
compare his bro they're brothers
okay hey here's the thing though are you
and jay both good at football
yeah we are okay so so with the ball
brothers yeah
so but here's here's what's weird cuz we
made this bet cleveland i've never lost
a bet to the
our whole group chat i know you know
this i've never lost a bet he's never
lost a bet
but also well white mike white mike
because
what you'd be white mike breaks off i
know you do
he said he goes but he never reports his
losses you guys would know my law i only
bet you guys
or i bet uh fighting and i only bet
fighting if i know for a fact
well fighting is different because
you're gonna be yeah we don't like
mike's eating he goes man
he don't even report his losses who are
like you guys would know
i really bet you guys you tell me what
you know you and i
never lost it no you know what it is you
started you started
right you're hit up like hey malik
you're awfully quiet this weekend i'm
like you're the same
oh the way he tried to bully you with a
10 point thank you with the team give me
ten points
bro give me tim he does that on purpose
so he was like all right
exactly we'll give you six we'll give
you five and he was like what's vegas
numbers
vegas is like 5.5 give me seven
that's higher than vegas and like you
know what we'll give you six give me six
you guys are talking all that [ __ ] no
i figured i could get something out of
you before jay was like oh it's about to
be a landslide you know yeah
you're like just about to be beat down
all right put your money where your
mouth is
it's gonna be a beat down give me seven
that was a great bet because they didn't
have their coach
and a couple of players and we didn't
know you push nfl you push
pros with their backs against the wall
they're going to respond man you give
pros a reason to ball out
and pittsburgh hasn't played great since
[ __ ] week 11.
big ben 70 years old and severely out of
shape
what's up kids let's take a little break
from the shenanigans with the boys
because listen
with today's low interest rates it's a
great time to refinance your student
loans
it is time earnest offers low rate
student loan refinancing
and you can check your rate risk-free in
just two minutes that's right
two freaking minutes with earnest you
get radically
flexible payments and you can pick your
loan term
by refinance you can reduce your loan
term save money or combine multiple
loans into simple monthly payment
if you have questions you can even talk
to a real human
at earnest for help isn't it time you
stopped feeling overwhelmed by your
student debt
ernest is offering the t fat kz
listeners
100 cash bonus refinance your student
debt
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply
now ernest is giving you guys a 100
bonus refinance your student loans
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply
once again you get 100 cash bonus when
you visit earnest.com
fighter to refinance your student loan
not available in all states term
conditions apply
visit earnest.com fighter for details
terms conditions apply earnest student
loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc
and mls number one two zero four nine
one seven california finance and law
license numbers six
zero five four seven eight eight 303
seconds street
suite 401 north san francisco california
94107
visit earnest.com licenses for full list
of licenses
again that's earnest.com fighter this
episode of fighter and the kids is
brought to you by
manscaped who is the best in men's blow
the waist grooming big news manscape
just released their new cologne scent
to help you feel good and smell good all
over and at all times who knew smelling
this good
could feel good all right everyone knows
manscape has the perfect package 3.0
i've been harping about 3.0
forever but they didn't stop their
complete your grooming game with the new
re
defined cologne signature sent by
manscape
with the same signature scent that's all
in manscape formulas
this cologne is perfect all right
it is perfect be sure to check out the
perfect package 3.0 with all the
essentials for the below
the waist grooming needs including the
lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
all right yes i'm talking about they
have ball deodorant a toner to keep your
testes
at its besties and now you can use the
manscaped refined cologne to complete
your set and smell great anytime
anywhere
it's time to get your smell right get 20
off and free shipping with the code
fighter 20 at manscape.com your balls
and body will thank you get 20 off and
free shipping with code
fighter 20 on manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping
manscape.com use code fighter20 look
good smell good feel good
with mansgate big ben 70 years old
and severely out of shape well yeah
that's how i feel about drew brees but
again
we we oh next week hold on wait did you
man did you have the browns beating them
oh yeah and so we backed new jersey so i
said i said i want a classic
nets jersey kevin durant yeah the
classic the blue and yellow
blue and red it's hard meanwhile that's
it did you complete the purchase
did you get it well i couldn't find a
kevin durant so i would have found the
kim dragon sent you the link well
ebay has it well let jay have it wait
you're getting the kyrie in durant
no what'd you get me i did i got the
kyrie the link that you sent me
i bought that your fault did i send you
the character the carrier
is a little weird baller but a little
weird he's
again tonight what happened what
happened with kevin durant uh and
without kyrie they lost last night
guess who they lost so he needs to lose
to it's early season basketball so it
does not matter okay well the first 50
games don't give us a flying bro
listen i'm a big ravens fan now bet the
ravens over the bills now i know bills
is your home team i heard that you
walked in the stadium whatever
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whatever
hey
so i'm part of the bill's mafia i played
for the bills for three days okay i was
on the team
i was on team for six days
i still i still have access to the bills
mafia they support me all right you'll
see the importance let's see how i sell
tickets if i go to buffalo okay
bill's mafia comes out okay so i'm
rooting for the bills [ __ ] you i'm
rooting for those especially over the
ravens i'm not a ravens fan all right so
make a bet
what do you want to bet bro bad jerseys
again
all right what are you doing do you want
another lamella no
i don't want mike right i don't want my
name associated lamilla balls
purchased transaction
i'm gonna use cash all right give me the
luca doncic city edition jersey
all right what the white and gold one
all right all right bet and then i don't
know who i want
okay you think about it but yeah lamar
did you see what he did
okay but here's my thing though yeah why
do y'all keep betting him
then you talk [ __ ] during the game it's
not looking good for you fellas
i sent a link to the jersey i went 28
nothing
this is the jersey i said hit me up when
the order is complete
that's some books that is [ __ ] he
does bully
you bet jay tonight on the national
championship yeah yeah uh
i'm not feeling comfortable with that i
bet justin i know i don't feel would you
bet he bet the points he said uh i have
ohio state plus
eight yeah it's so not a great bad me
and jay had the same bet
you so you were you're generally alabama
remember he took alabama you and i took
ohio state
because i think because jay roots for
ohio state because you know oh he did
everything meyer's a friend
we always [ __ ] with ohio state and then
we're talking about [ __ ] and then
you're like i'll give you [ __ ] you
know you're like oh state plus aj is
like i'll take alabama but i even got a
bet with my girl on that game
my queens did you oh yeah she was a ohio
she went to ohio state
yeah good school i know so yeah no what
does she say the ohio
yeah sorry uh what is it it starts that
stands for something she'll kill me she
always say the uh
honored excellence honor x yeah
something something like that but the d
stands for something weird um
you can't just be a buck guys thing yeah
you can't disrespect all the experts
like
clay travis who i listen to all the time
on usually on pro sports he he usually
makes bets and how did you roll off his
bets clayton travis yes
he's he's a big homie right yeah okay
but he uh
he had experts on every single like
people doing college football for like
40 years
they're like this game ain't going to be
close
you're about to beat the shim which i
don't i don't know dude or i hope not i
know how they
yeah hello so you you you have ohio
state
yeah they both have all yesterday i
don't know i don't know
i might have been just in shoes i assume
we all better shoes yeah
damn bro speaking of shoes oh yeah
sneaker here let the people know i'm
addicted
let the people know i'm addicted to
shoes yeah i said i sent this new this
new jordan ford low tops coming out i
went yo
join five i send them to the group chat
i'm like check these out
chappelle text me oh you don't text me
off the group chat when i'll check with
my guy
i'm addicted you've been wearing vans
for the last 20 years two weeks ago
two weeks ago your first pair of jordans
let me talk to my guys
bro i'm telling you man it's insane it's
it's the colors
yeah they're so nice it's dope it's
always going to have a new uh like i
find i see these colors and they're just
oh and i go oh they pretty together you
know what i'm saying tough right it's
i don't say pretty but yeah it's time
yeah i said whiskey peter everybody said
he worth it oh yeah
i sent him a bunch of kids i know about
it oh he did yeah
things i send some jordan one uh brand
new tar heel
yeah i sent the mars uh
air max 90s why am i so addicted do you
get addicted are you addicted bro yeah
yeah yeah we've been a dude
how do you think you got here
hey you guys like shoes
i love like how he came around and just
started wearing vans he's just started
peeping like everyone definitely
not just like busted house but yeah he's
slipping
busted that's the story the all-white
prison yard yeah
the bruce lee's the bruce
what's the first thing i said to you
when i got when i came outside
to you uh today oh you showed me uh like
hey
hey look i was like hey dog what do you
think you know i've been texting him all
the time
yeah let's see uh cause he didn't want
to put it in the group chat because i
want y'all ragging on me to see what
shoes i like so i'm making sure i'm
doing a good job
so i'm going to hit some dope out of
shoes i'm the shoe guy
but he's not going to he's not going to
rag on me he's not going to make me feel
better
like jordan foreign
i remember a couple of like prior texts
you go you mean
no no no no wait wait he goes wait wait
he goes jordan's he was like yo hey what
did you think about these
he's like yeah they're all right they're
cool but you should get these that's a
nice way of saying
they're ugly chappelle don't don't get
though i forget what shoe it was
you know what i'm talking about was it
recent no it's like it was like a lot
but it was like a wild chew if you don't
have a lot of shoes you don't want
oh yeah it was it was a weird but you
know but the confidence you had
in the group chat i did them a [ __ ]
solid thing because
i must reply no but he's gonna be nice
to me yeah none of us replied we just
let you have he was like yo listen
yeah i wouldn't get those they're all
right but and i've seen the way because
you know what i've seen the way you're
going hard on uh malik's uh
madagascar twos well let's not bring
that out i mean they still they're not
terrible are we not calling it what it
is they're nike
they're nice i don't give a [ __ ] nike
misses too man
they missed on those yeah
it's easy i could just [ __ ] pick him
out if you talk to jay though he's
always gonna push on some random new
balance or something oh my god yeah he
stays on new balance that's why i'm
happy making his bet with jay i don't
know he's going to make it he'll what
cha balances get expensive though papa
really i'm telling you the new the new
balance collabs and they're hard to get
if he if he gets one of those you'll be
dropping some money
so like you're doing balances oh yeah
dude like the kyries or they have like
these they're
harry's not no he's not a new balance
not kind of uh
kawhi kawaii oh uh he gets old no but
they have new ones are they dope are
they they're white
i saw the first fruity pebble uh the
kawaii new balances no they they have
some the
uh new balance dropped some collabs that
are ridiculous
those which ones which yeah
they're like more of a it's not
basketball shoes it's the pink ones
scroll all the way over there
look at those fruity pebbles i was like
this one no
no it's like a regular shoe those are
the basketballs oh it's like the the
regular
they've been doing some dope [ __ ] though
i have some new balances my grateful
dead new balance is that hiking they're
great
oh that was not expensive oh no they're
expensive because dude they're very
expensive
those grateful deads are like 200 bucks
stuck like new balances don't [ __ ]
around they're
new balance grateful dead yeah you never
seen my like tie-dye
woodstock grateful dead no no can we
really pull those up
you were a tie-dye oh yeah like a
[ __ ]
the green one or the orange those are
the dogs i've seen those
no you've seen those those are nikes
they're new balances
they're like a woodstock they're sick i
was on a new balance
wednesday also you're talking about shoe
cam now listen i was telling you this
oh shoe cam in here yeah at the end of
the episode we need to have chin take
the camera off and zoom in on our kicks
oh that's how i'm
staring out this camera when you guys
are done taking pictures uh well just
yeah yeah
jay said fans are complaining that they
can't see our kicks we'll just put it on
just put it to the ear like see now
that's a lot of pressure for me
see now now the fans want to see the
shoes and guess what i got to do
get more [ __ ] shoes yeah yeah jordan
these these are jordans just when he
reached out
and like had like the monsters on the
spaceship you know i mean
those are the spaceships this is space
jams this is a shoe cam right here you
put it through so what what
do i have again but i feel you okay what
but i feel you but i feel you you're
excited about your dreams yeah yeah
the ones i've been had i saw your energy
i always took my shoe off yeah i don't
know what i'm saying
you see what he did yeah he does that's
what he's doing this is not the time for
shoe cam
i can't do in the middle of the episode
podcast skills got to get up what i'm
saying is now there's now that's a lot
of pressure the fans want to see the
shoes
yeah of course of course these are most
these are the most shoes i've ever had
in my life
you got to keep coming keep it yeah yeah
yeah two pairs of vents bro do you know
those would be but you have a new
contact
though that can get you some kicks
you don't want to bless the group either
no that's kind of stuff is it really
no it's not i don't know i don't know i
don't know the etiquette it's not
selfish
listen get your shoes don't post it
because they post it
they'll have my shoes now i can't wear
my shoes anymore
they're certain shoes i can make you huh
no bro hold on
hold on no justin don't know and then
justin be like
damn man you're like damn right y'all
you remind me of shoes we didn't we
forgot about i'm like what the [ __ ]
listen i i like those wither spoons you
have those with this with the spoons
right i was like damn i mean i've been
meaning to get those
i've been pushing into this i saw
brendan no no okay
i'm starting to make a little money now
remind you of them you did remind me but
but at the same time what about my
presto off-whites
impossible to get what about my jordan
uh off-white ones
impossible to get again brennan again
i'm fine financially now when i'm
packing for our shows on the weekend you
got a
big white guy let's shoot this malek and
joke
it's so funny because steve you'll
message me because we have a we have a
same pair of
the royals yeah the royals yeah we have
that yeah i didn't know
you couldn't rock the same as your homie
because no you can't you know my homies
with vans yeah we just rock them but
the shoes is you know what i'm saying
they started now
they're forty dollars so of course
everyone else i love how you compare
vans to like
he's he's new he's hey there's some
dopey
yeah yeah see what'd you guys do this
weekend what i do
i went to riverside like i always do
that's that's where your
gay friend lives right mm-hmm yeah what
did you do out there went inside a
restaurant
how about jay text me on friday night i
go you know what me and you always take
care of that [ __ ] what are you doing
guys i'm in a restaurant
i went damn you bowled how are you
you living in 2024 restaurant i said
denver's open he said [ __ ] we've been
open has it been
i guess so he went at a sushi den which
is like the best sushi in denver out
there oh wow
wide open hug damn but notice uh
governor cuomo today was like hey
because they're all like oh [ __ ] because
businesses
just can't do this cuomo tweeted out
today was like
uh we got to start opening things up and
restaurants
we're losing too much business if we
wait and we come back there's gonna be
nobody to which is right
there'll be no businesses to save come
on so now was like oh [ __ ]
the notice newsome has shut the [ __ ] up
since that recall
they're at a million signatures they
need a million and a half oh i heard you
go to the board
they're gonna get that yeah yeah that
boy is stressed yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
prick
ooh okay yeah
i think that wall i mean
is starting it's making me creative yeah
you gotta get creative with it bro guess
what i did for my shorty
what you do what you do let's hear it i
move all the furniture out
move it right i was like hey just come
over i'm going to set up some
dope for you you just said your crib oh
yeah yeah so i had i moved the furniture
had a big blanket put it on the floor
put it on the floor
big black yeah i ordered post mates her
favorite restaurant
well what is it come on
sushi but it comes in boxes yeah so well
done you open up that white box
do you get like to go to go to go uh
it's tucked me into something like that
it's that one
yeah that one right there yes i can't
she don't like to add a mommy you can't
touch that oh man
like that bro you gotta show your face
it's a surcharge of like 13 if you order
from there from postmates now oh yeah
oh yeah yeah because they're uh in uber
eats they have a
surgery yeah you get sugar fish it's red
panty night dog oh yeah yeah
yeah well she already knew what it was
because that's just like baby indoor
picnic
get that indoor people don't then i turn
the tv no you can go outside but well no
no you can't go outside you turn the tv
on and then 65 inch she bought me yeah
bro put the background on and it was
like a fire
bro not even fire it was like other
people outside like somebody's right
there like maybe
sushi hell no okay yeah yeah you know
you're a picky [ __ ] so you just you
did that for her
i had a turkey sandwich this
[ __ ] is turkey sandwiches
but wait wait
that's cool she's all using chopsticks
and [ __ ]
you did a little uh and i had a candle
so you did a little date night yeah
what would you do uh yeah once uh
you went to oh yeah i did two shows over
the weekend i did jam in the van again
on out uh
santa monica they do at the same place
there's different places yeah same place
it's pretty dope
i like it is there a van in the
background or that has nothing to do
with the van
the van's outside outside of the little
that lets you know that you're at the
right venue if you see the van
yeah and is it like it is kind of like
they're like an underground it's like a
speakeasy like
it's no it's it's kind of like uh they
promote backyard it looks like a
backyard but
the way they have it set up yeah oh and
it's like who's in charge
i don't know it's usually the people so
they just hit up comedians
to run shows and then the comedians
they'll just hit me up i've had a few
people hit me up to do it yeah
rappaport does it all the time yeah
rappaport does it uh tiffany haddish did
it yeah she did
um who else did it bill bird did it
right
no he usually does that magic castle
yeah i don't know if he's done jam of
the van yet
oh yeah uh so you did that and you did
another show too
uh-huh yeah the other show was in the
backyard
it was my brother-in-law's b-day so we
had a b-day party for him but we just i
watched football with my
uh father-in-law all [ __ ] weekend uh
that's it how was it it was great
yeah wild card it's nothing better than
wild card weekend football
oh my god what does that mean it's like
the player winner go home
you know he's like yeah and you have so
they play play yeah like
they can you know they play that's when
they really go hard all out like aaron
donald bald the [ __ ] out
bro more jackson come on baker mayfield
like so the pressure's on oh yeah this
is where you like make your career so
like baker mayfield he's like
he's looking for an extension so he
needs a ball to get that money
dog didn't you ball was you was you yeah
i think i got to give you a credit he
was like soon as obj got hurt now that's
my guy lsu
i love him he was like yo he's just
they're gonna they're gonna ball out i
was like
he does better yeah he does better
because he's pressure it's less pressure
and then he's forcing the ball to obj so
he has more turnovers
so since obj left i heard shannon sharp
say this this morning
i think he's like 14 touchdowns or two
intercepts like he's balling since
because you got to force him the ball he
has landry he has
angry yeah that's all you need and you
got that dope tight end you got good
chubs the running back like they're
stacked
no they could they could beat uh chiefs
what
they could beat the chiefs what you
thinking give me 15 points i'm not
giving
you this
then he goes he goes what's vegas line
i'm like oh it's like seven okay
i bet it's higher than chin check the uh
the line on the cheese versus the browns
i bet you it's at least eight you just
tell i never had anything i just want to
keep betting
wait the cheese versus oh you think you
think the browns can beat the cheese is
that what you said
i like to think so is that it
wait currently that's over under keep
scrolling down yeah
9.5 favorites yeah almost 10 points see
i said give me 10 points
15. it's going to move well yeah vegas
sets a line then they want you to put
money on the other team so the lines get
to move yeah
they'll probably be eight by the time
game day seven
that's a lot of points in that seven
points nfl's a lot of that's a lot of
points usually it's like
one and a half threes a lot four if it's
like getting
a blow you gotta understand and if the
grounds are hot right now so
i would not take that and then the
cheese guys said they could see
no no i'm not saying i'm not saying
they're going to win
i i want brown's bills in the
championship
yeah that's not going to happen those
are my teams i want i want patrick
mahomes and lamar jackson but we bet uh
bill's ravens
okay straight up yeah straight up no no
no points no point
yep okay cool i'm glad i'm like i'm not
getting into this world
you got me in the shoes yeah i ain't
getting into the bed slowly slowly
no i don't watch it enough because
there's not money on it's just like
dope stuff making my home yeah shoes
yeah jerseys you know
i feel better buying yourself you got to
use your money you can post money i'm
like
bro i gotta yeah it hurts me to give
like money hurts like here's your
if it's like a pair of shoes you're like
oh this is dope no yeah it's a gift but
it
feels different it's like imagine
british is taking a thousand from me
like hey man
remember your bonus yeah thanks guys
let's keep doing this i want to drink so
bad this weekend oh yeah how are you
doing i'm all right you're doing good
i felt like uh my quality of life was
better when i was drinking like my back
hurts now
i'm not sleeping i'm not sleeping as
good
yeah i felt way better when i was
boozing oh yeah oh i wanted to drink so
bad this weekend
they were all drinking oh damn yeah
congratulations
sitting back yeah close man i was close
i didn't though
you lied you were like i asked my
grandma i said
i said i've been sober for three weeks
now my girl's like [ __ ] it's been
11. why can't i count the longest 11
days
you like denzel in flight when he opened
that fridge oh yeah
are you drunk i'm drunk right now are
you going to drink in austin
yes you are that'd be the first time i
drink because that's basically that's 30
days
that's january 29th the last time your
drink was what nyu
i had was on stage at palm palm beach
and that was the first that was uh
new year's eve whatever oh yeah it'll be
the first yeah yeah it'll be fun yeah
so it's almost 30 days wait no i thought
it was 30 times
i'm drinking really
i'm counting it down you're counting it
down yeah kadoosh i'm jonesing
you knows it dog i just like a good
good taste do you feel like you're
yourself right now ah did i feel like
what you're yourself like do you i i
feel better when i'm drinking
i sleep better like i'm telling my back
starting to hurt now
like my joints hurt
i mean yeah we're rooting for you i mean
i'm doing it right
clean up my diet i get meals at the crib
now hey we're doing it
hey i'm telling you when we get to
awesome though it's on yeah it's on
yeah we're gonna we're gonna strict a
lot i just you know what texas just has
such great food and i
can't [ __ ] resist that bro why do it
out there i can't resist
we're going to let loose coming out yeah
we got jessie coming out tattoo dude
oh yeah y'all getting everything yeah
you know what love island makes you want
to do oh [ __ ] here you go you know what
i love island
i want to tattoo my leg now dawg why why
you want to i thought you had one on
your leg
what do you want your thigh or something
like that i want one on my thigh
wait i want a full i want like a sleeve
on my left leg
oh you do yeah what you gonna get i
don't know
i don't know get the rock on you they
get the rock on you or something
get fit to get 15 points padded on you
or something like that
i get 30 days
do you know do you know good uh
restaurants out there oh yeah in austin
for sure
san marcos i've never been i don't know
but one of the producers on uh below the
belt daniel
went to school there so he's gonna send
us some recommendations but austin i
know all the spots
bro i gotta do you guys like thai food
yeah i love thai food oh yeah the best
thai foods out there
you like thai food bro i got introduced
i figured out
why like uh so now like
since i so i i have some uh issues with
covert right so i
we all know that covid well documented i
lost my taste in uh
smell can you do anything yet bro so
this is what's weird
is um my coffees if you drink my coffee
it's
so it will knock you on your dick yeah
and to me it's normal
like uh spicy i went for mean like kind
of spicy because
i can eat crazy spicy like you can't
make it spicy i'm cool
i'm cool it's because of kovit dug damn
my taste never came back 100
so that's why like when like whiskey
like 100 proof [ __ ] used to bother me i
can guzzle hunter proof now
it don't matter you don't gotta say
guzzle but yeah i mean you keep telling
to shove a
hundred proof now yeah it's because of
code broke they say cobra gives you
superpowers though
no well my cardio is better but the
thing is is my
oh do you really feel like your cardio
is better my taste my taste never came
back fully
so i have to drink real strong coffee to
get that's
dangerous though that's dangerous i know
dangerous to the alcohol
it's like it's not with spice and
everything and it's like with people
with the pain tolerance
well no with the spice i remember you
ate it you was like y'all some [ __ ]
and he was on
on the toilet for like 4 00 a.m well my
stomach is like yes
but my taste buds can they yeah the
stomach's like
they're not back 100 will you ever get
them back you think i don't i mean it's
been
months no there's i've known people to
uh lose it and get it back yeah
really yeah mm-hmm what about one of my
homies yeah he
i mean he got it like a month ago uh my
homie in riverside
uh he got it but yeah he still can't he
and he ate something uh
that was rotten he didn't know until the
stomach got all [ __ ] up
yeah yeah but like mine just aren't bad
it's like if they were at 10 before
probably never 10 if they're 10
i'm at like a seven now so my cop like
anyone like my mother-in-law father or
my girl try the coffee like holy [ __ ]
dude oh really i'm like it's just
it's just tasty this is really bad to
them to me it's normal yeah
is it this [ __ ] yeah try this this is
like
panicking just try
just try a sip of it it's karma time
there's actually a jamaican remedy
that's been going around because of
kovid where it's supposed to help you
get your taste back a lot of people are
charring
uh oranges and then what you'll do is
you smash up the orange you put a bunch
of honey and cinnamon in it and then you
eat the
orange and it should give you your taste
buds that's amazing all day no it's
jamaican no jamaican
thanks to sean paul
we were making fun of love island
because um season five and six they
bring out these
it's so strong are you okay yeah that's
gross so strong
you still leaving your hair like that
though
no i'm just no dog we talked about
braids
remember i don't know i approached the
braids and they were hanging girls
you were hating on the hat the way you
delivered it right now
you heard that delivery yeah bro i'm not
listening to fans bro
so i was talking about like i need a new
barber there's one guy sent me i i i
want to
tell you they telling you to find a new
one yeah but look he was like i do have
yep of course max skin dude yes yeah you
got one
no no no all he does is braids i was
like what the [ __ ]
maxine does braids yes all elsa i don't
need my hair braided
he does well but he was like yeah bro
but i don't know his photos he was
sitting in
like dudes yeah he was sitting in the
dude's leg
i don't know i don't know what he is
yeah oh no you want you want if he
wanted
he want to do your hair he won't do you
doing he
you want some big like manly like damn
dog you be working out
no man you want a little sugar you
little timber headed
the style i'm trying you don't think i
can pull it off
why you keep moving dawg i'm gonna tell
you again
you say you won't twist or admit
individuals
individuals well you already got mine no
damn dawg
you look better in twists yeah but what
you say yeah
you don't think i can pull it off
honestly i
i love my man but i don't think you can
pull it off
now let me give you my reasons right but
what what that is
ross has it go to terence ross
oh yeah his brains look good yeah he
wasn't
um uh henry has that piece of
dookie hanging on the back of his helmet
it's not no dookie that's dress
but that's one thick dookie dress uh no
not right there
oh no no no nothing why it's hell no
yeah right no you can't really tell
there gee well there's another picture
jersey we saw three pictures of his
brains and you're not about to get you
get that so
you don't think i can do that gee the
upkeep on those braids and we are let's
let's be honest maintenance yes there's
a lot of maintenance
you don't think i can do that i have a
lot of sisters that have a lot of weeds
and they have a lot of tracks
right you they always keep the upkeep
it's like two or three days
bro look at your hair now one last time
you brushed your sides that's the
good point just underneath honestly when
the last time you took a brush like oh
[ __ ] is out of order let me brush this
out yeah that's out of order let me just
just
just answer i'm in order just answer the
question your hair all over
why
why why why are you coming at me like
now you're saying why
no but you don't think i can pull it off
bro you can't i used to have braids
i know but that was back in it listen i
think it would look dope you look like
deontay walter yeah
i love it yeah just face the sides and
it's just those two of you
look at that look at deontay water with
those dreads and fade decide good
he was going through some [ __ ] that's
like rallying with the do-rag
yeah he was trying to figure out his
life he was like well [ __ ] i'm just
about to get the dairy here that's a lot
that was not yeah that's yeah he looks
better that right there but look
that's a lot of maintenance dog i'm
trying to tell you
what makes you think i'm not going to
take time man listen you can at least
explore it let me yeah i'm exploring
everything i'm getting new shoes
yeah right everybody yes losing weight
yeah losing weight
bro i'm working on new outfits are you
losing weight though
yes i i'm working on i saw you got a
little dyson when you said that question
i mean we're trying what hold on now
don't disrespect yeah
he acts like i just been eating bad the
whole time or some [ __ ]
i told you i cut you off yeah i listen i
support your
weight loss i'm just saying from my
peepers
you look exactly the same people i love
how you called over their
glasses it's different you see me all
the time so someone that don't see me
all the time is gonna be like dang
chappelle
you look great i'm living wait i'm
living maybe
i'm getting stronger i like mine because
that's how you see me i see you every
single day i know
do you think he's losing weight cat he
looks healthier in my opinion if i'm
being honest like he looks like he's not
like as soft anymore
okay thank you jin you agree
i see chappelle every day too so i can't
tell i mean
that's a no from chin that's it that's
him no that's him being polite
would just
let's go to the asian what do you think
chen said uh i think he meant what he
says
chin doesn't say [ __ ] that he doesn't
mean i'll take that straight up chin
why you got to deliver it that way
honestly
i think i think you're losing weight man
thank you i've really been doing it now
now
now
lost 15 pounds she did she got body [ __ ]
for it
and she got she did it she did it she
lost 15 pounds she really did she looked
great
dj khaled been working now look
all
now dj khaled been working out for two
years i'm not alone oh
come on don't use don't compare me to he
didn't have it
you didn't lose it you always had the
towel
and giving like the energy quotes
god didn't want you to wake up but you
did you see it's time to go get it
oh come on that's a pretty big
difference that's a different outfit ah
man
that's a difference
this is a big house i'm trying to
encourage people that are losing weight
all i see is on this oh no the shoe
collection no yeah yeah
no seriously what else oh he's like
how's business
yeah booming that boy's thick thing he's
dick yeah
would you originally this weekend i see
rick ross in the back
uh i also had sugar fish oh yeah this
one yeah
sugar fish is it is it like everywhere
the why i live closer to here now so i
think it's here and there's also
vista yeah in downtown l.a i'm not sure
they got one uh right
this one calabasas oh is it on la brea
yep
yeah and on that corner yeah we passed
by they're kind of all over they're not
it's not like a huge chain but they're
over but they have a few
in l.a yeah you had an indoor picnic as
well or not indoor picnic okay and we
drink alcohol
would you have sake you're not doing the
dough dry no no i haven't
i thought you're gonna do it with me
chin you were all encouraging it it
sounded nice for you man
when i got home i'm like i just want to
sip you didn't go inside yeah when i got
home i was like
long day me too grab a bite it's a nice
way to just
relax wind down yeah it's so nice there
you go we'll see if i last to austin
she went to a badass place this weekend
i went to lake arrowhead
oh yeah it was nice i wanted to go see
the snow i took my sister and stevie
with me we went and grabbed uh
what they had the water bottle right the
what the airhead water bottle
okay yeah arrowhead it's super nice
there it's not packed at all
oh wasn't it oh yeah okay okay
look hey my face is the shade but my
body is the sun
i see what you did in that picture no i
was a good captain oh i thought i was
like is that what our captain said
you know what i'm saying try to read
this [ __ ] get glasses
gee what get glasses the way you squint
at the tv
i know people people keep messaging me
you're going to get speech
look at stevie in the background stevie
doing the best
just having fun i uh i love lake
arrowhead by the way
it's gorgeous my girlfriend i went there
for uh the fourth of july
i've never been it's it's really did you
guys you guys just did you stay the
night
no i drove up because my sister was sad
for
a few weeks so i decided to cheer up and
take her to the snow before it all
melted
that's nice but why was she sad i mean
why she's in the business though
thank you why she down
no she and her are very similar where
like uh every few months we just have a
bow of sadness
like we're just sat she has uh
depression too uh kind of she's bipolar
i have depression anxiety so like every
now and then like we go through like
ebbs and flows like
usually if i'm not bad she's bad if
she's not bad i'm bad so we can take
care of each other
that's good so i just wanted to go cheer
up do you have panic attacks
yeah i used to have panic attacks so
much where i wouldn't leave my house for
two weeks oh my god
you seem better now yeah yeah i am
better i think uh i
took your advice i am staying off social
media more and that helped a lot
yeah yeah and then like going out into
nature is good too i just feel like i've
been cooped up inside for too long for
sure
nature helps a lot and then your sister
what's go what's going on with her she
has anxiety for ohio state game or
whatever
uh no um her is just randomly kind of
sad
but also she wants to be on love island
usa oh
over the weekend we actually applied now
while she applied i helped her so the
producer
uh for below they hired new producers
she came from love island usa so i
wonder if she really needs contacts
my sister needs love her sister is such
a baddie too i know what can't do do you
think she could get on the show
well hold on now hold on now your sister
can we yeah i don't know
like how they would cast i heard that
they cast through instagram profiles
i bet you're your sister's a baddie i
don't know what her instagram is yeah
let's see let's go
let's look can i act as a love love
island producer and share it okay let me
go for it the same casting couch now
but on uh i only watched love island uk
there's never been an
asian person god damn yep she hired oh
my god
everybody's looking at the net
what's her tattoo uh she has a medusa
tattoo
oh okay oh shh look at those eyes cat
damn it super baddie oh my
god now is she good on her current bills
and all that
uh yeah i mean if you want to
help she's all for taking that out
what'd she get her degree in
uh she got her degree and i believe
public health she's working on an
optometrist
oh hello how old is she she is 23. okay
she's working on optometrist
yeah for real yeah yeah you know what
that is do you need an eye exam
yeah yeah yeah i need a [ __ ] eye
exactly okay we'll set it up
yeah oh it's good because it's been a
minute i'm trying to people i'm tired of
y'all signing into my dm's talking about
get some glasses oh no
yeah yeah i got a lot of glaucoma it
runs in my family
oh [ __ ] glaucoma that's really good
that's not good yeah i also need to go
in my vision's not great
oh that's weird suddenly all the time
i genuinely would like to get a high
exam well i'll set it up i failed my
wait you know what triggers your panic
attacks uh
a lot of it is kind of random here you
know like it's here and there and then
sometimes it's just like
if my heart rate gets elevated even if
i'm not stressed out my body will think
i'm having a panic attack
when it's not that it's just like a
disorganized attack maybe
for me it's like i can't stop crying no
my intentions no
not necessarily it's like it's almost
like this feeling of fight or flight
like i like something is coming after me
and i need to get away from it but i
don't know
what the threat is you can't my god yeah
like i can't like pinpoint what the
threat
is and so it makes me feel crazy because
it's like there's no reason for me to be
stressed out or worrying about like
everything but suddenly like i freeze it
does the pandemic make it worse
uh so far no i think the pandemic
doesn't necessarily help it doesn't make
it worse
yeah i think what made it worse was like
anxiety
i had a panic attack yeah that's what
i'm saying every time i listen to
pharrell i'm happy
i have that feeling what [ __ ] really are
you trying to make a joke out of her
brother no no no no
no no the fear the fear listen the fear
of someone's coming after you
i swear to god that song the beat cause
i'm happy i'm like yo this is just
annoying
so you you see it as a cynical like
because i'm happy like like it's like
like
well good thing it's not 2016 malik and
you're good because no one's playing
that [ __ ] song
they still play that song you listen to
the radio still i know right
now no radio is playing that bro you
don't listen to the radio yeah i do
they're not playing that song oh my god
okay anyways
big boys neighborhood ain't playing that
one i'm not listening
to ktla now
ladies came on and it's [ __ ]
chickadee china i'm telling you dude i
freak out on people hey do you hear like
when uh i don't want to go into
conspiracy theories but
i want to explain this pen a second do
you go into it i swear
i swear to god i just have bad anxiety
so um
remember that day i had that coffee yeah
and i was like man like i feel did you
have a baby
when you had that one sip
you see what this is there's no problem
there's no problem
wow both of us have enough pentagons
but uh a fan had messaged me yeah he was
like hey man
you might have like a panic disorder and
he goes because coffee can do that to
people
yeah sometimes it could trigger yeah and
uh i looked it up and all that stuff and
that's what i was feeling
from that from that coffee eat a dick
now
i respond back day i thanks fauci no i
said i said thanks i said thanks
you know and then he was like yeah man
you know just uh i thought i'd help you
out you know big fan and yeah
also i love the man that you're becoming
he really said that i was like bro you
know
much less so you had to agree with that
but anyways yeah some of the shows at
san marcos now
that's some [ __ ] i'm
the coffee gave me anxiety yeah because
like well
coffee has done that before you know
what i mean like from time to time
depending on where
i get it from like that's why i'll go
just give me one shot
well here one shot is two they don't
tell you that
i have to try to get the inside from the
lady because i was like oh i was like
put more than two in there she's like no
doug
so one's two here yeah she's like if you
go to uh
starbucks one is one here are one it's
two that's why the coffee is so strong
and that's not i don't know that's why
i don't know the coffee's turning around
i got [ __ ] up that day what's two
what's
you didn't drink a lot of it but yeah
yeah but i was feeling it immediately
you just might be sensitive caffeine if
your sense of caffeine how to do it but
it was making me like freak out and i
was just like
thank you like i was getting like a like
a head rush
type i don't know i don't start wheezing
a little bit no i don't get that stuff
my stuff if there's like a like i'm
trying to get a deal closed or something
like [ __ ] going on oh god it's like
in this just it's not like i can't it's
not up to me to close it or it's
not up to me to finish it or when things
are out of your control
my anxiety died so
[Music]
his
you know that's a terrible reference
right you said yeah
so if mine is short that doesn't make
sense
i'm just trying to get to the logic yeah
i'll get bad
bad anxiety if it's out of my control
yeah bro i tend to sleep with weighted
blankets when i'm
feeling really anxious those people say
they're so i
love those guess with me and my queen i
love them
oh yeah it's like i don't know what the
science behind it is but like when
no it's just like a heavier blanket it's
like a big blanket that weighs about
like five to ten pounds
you put it over your body the weight
calms you down oh i need a bigger one
than that yeah also
you need to get this have you heard of a
heated towel
like a hot towel no i heat it like it
like listen so
it comes in the hamper you see it by the
bathtub right
and you put it in your towel that you
want to like dry off with yeah and it's
like it warms it up for like
as long as your beds wet no no it's it's
just dry
it's hot but then you know how like
people like love hot towels i mean my
queen got that and it's
it's a hamper you ever heard of a heated
blanket malik you know you can
plug it into the wall and it gets hot
yeah but you see that's too much work so
once you get out this
shower or the tub you just get that
little it's so great isn't it and
the warmth is perfection you can
navigate the heat
right and as soon as you get on your
your cold or like wet body
it dries up tell me what you're drying
off how this
absorbs yeah it's absorbs and it's heat
as well go ahead chin down weighted
blanket they gotta look at that right
there hell yeah
they're like a 40 pounder no no we got
that we ain't got that we got the honey
oh so you put it in that yup that one
right there go ahead oh you guys have a
device
yeah i thought you're talking about just
driving i know yeah i thought you were
like talking about go to the shower
yeah turn on the shower come on you ever
get out of the shower you're all wet
and then what you know oh no this is a
hand dresser oh no we do we got we got
it's a bigger we don't got that but
listen
yeah go to you got something like that
let's go we don't need your exact one
but yeah we'll go to the one with the
wait but why do you and your girl do
this
look at that look at that one that's my
queen yeah what is it yeah digging in
you see it with the lips oh that's right
that one right there yeah but why do you
guys do this because it calms you down
like let's say you have a stressful day
you're like i want to take a bath and
you have the candles lit
and not only you want to finish that
like completion of just relaxation
you get out the shower and then that
waited i'm not waiting that hot
towel just like absorbs all that
negativity you had all the toxic
all that yeah everything it just takes
all your problems and you just get you
put it on a
little towel rack and then she comes in
and you make love
boom damn
what do you think of it if it works for
him i mean i jump in the hot tub
you know what i'm saying yeah this
[ __ ] just wait god damn that's
just yeah
you caught me in there yeah right the
end tiger in our speed yeah
because i was coming over to pick up
some shoes and he's like yeah the gate
is over man just come around back
and i come around back sometimes he had
his horse
came over yeah and a hot tub is your
sister doing better now
yeah she's doing a lot after the trip
yeah we did that and then we made uh a
bunch of grilled cheese sandwiches
i'm telling you so good what kind of
what kind of youtube uh stevie made
a uh sweet grilled cheese so it was goat
cheese
uh honey walnuts and then uh rosemary
butter it was so good
you don't like that at all really no i
don't know i don't put stevia
no thank you good really great grilled
cheese man
it's really good it's like a vegan it's
like a vegan kind of thing right
stevie's going to make it for us in
austin he makes really good no not like
walnut cheese like
he puts water actually yeah oh yeah no
it's good
i'll try it did he use that uh artisan
bread or whatever yeah he's like an
artisan sourdough
yeah brioche buns are the best bread
though
delicious is good yeah potato rolls
right now grilled cheese
i'm telling you let stevie make you
[ __ ] or grill nuts are you
serious
you never make [ __ ] on the road i know
he does he makes himself some
hard-boiled eggs that's true
that sounds about right yeah but if he
does make it he's it's good he knows how
to make a groceries
uh phoenix
out there yeah bro that was us getting
to know each other yeah we didn't know
each other yeah exactly what do you mean
i knew stevie already
you know yeah thank you yeah but i mean
we've been there so many times in the
introduction
that was a pizza he's like i come
oh yeah commercial commercial on
thursday okay yeah i can't wait
jay bayless we're gonna do a show on
friday
yesterday what show chappelle
i got chapelle listen listen i usually
i'm the dumb one
right but today on this monday it might
be your haircut i don't know maybe start
brushing
your thoughts your haircut is off yeah
so so let's house it off
bro let's just cut off what's your
thoughts and i'm trying to tell you look
at that turn to the camera let me show
you what i see
i don't know what you think i paid 60
dollars
for this [ __ ] turn your head
that's pissing me off on the back
hold on let me just show you what is it
she's gonna just just look at cat
right there just stay like right hold on
wait wait let me get it briefly
just so you know why we're frustrated
why is it frustrating right well stay
there
okay there it is look at that [ __ ] there
that's this i wanna show you what
i see and why
we're frustrated oh
that's because i think it's pillow
whatever it is
i got hot head you know i got i sleep on
pillows but i comb my [ __ ] cuz i'm the
last person to talk about a haircut so
what should i get
bro get get a due rack get a do-rack or
get a brush we're just gonna flatten it
all out if i get a d-ring
bro listen to me you what's your and
then i'll be on stage like you
would a do-rag and [ __ ] jesus
jesus i'm not getting the t-rex they
call me they was calling me mally g
all weekend you see what we're talking
about though
on the picture and it doesn't look that
bad do you put any product in yeah first
of all
the people can't see the back of my head
but we can
and your thoughts are coming out okay
yeah it's called it's stupidity it's
stupidity
bro i'm not i can't think straight look
at my hair
let's see your hair oh
you've been waiting for that right
that's why he's been waiting
he's been waiting for that [ __ ] i hope
they asked you to take that i hope they
ask me
yeah i'll take it please i'm gonna take
it off like it's a gender reveal
god's plan god's plan
yeah [ __ ] out of here you're distracting
from the message
what's the message i would clean it up
that is true should i really
no seriously you think so no we're not
it's a good haircut
what's your girl say about it huh what's
your girl say about it she don't care
right
i don't know she doesn't say that no
she just likes it she just hates when my
hair is like super short
what's she what's she thinking about the
braids oh yeah she said she likes it
yeah see yeah i think you should do it
why now why aren't you fine you know
listen i'm saying this look bro
do you put any product in your hair do
you put any product in your hair
oh yeah i do okay do you put product in
your hair i do not
okay well don't worry because you wonder
why we're back in the day
yeah i don't know if your mama ever did
this to you but they used to make us put
grease in our hair
of course yeah they're [ __ ] uh what's
that are you talking about
magic or bb's yeah yeah that [ __ ] that's
why i don't put product in my hair no
more why because i hated that [ __ ]
i hated having grease in my head well
because you know what grease does to
your hair
was it it makes it look presentable
first of all grease isn't actually good
for you
what do you mean there's no it's a
certain type of grease that's good for
your hair man what kind of what are your
favorite podcasts yeah what are you a
god damn
go go to a curtin adventure yes listen
2020 was tough
2021 is coming in hot kids
and you need somebody to talk to about
everything going on maybe out of anxiety
maybe you got depression
maybe you just want to talk to somebody
not your friend your friend might be a
dumbass
so talk to a licensed professional with
better help i'm talking about better
help
help like h-e-l-p better help there's
something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
let better help help you you can start
communicating with a real licensed
professional
in under 24 hours service is available
worldwide
log in your account anytime send a
message to your counselor and you get a
thoughtful response a timely thoughtful
response all right
it's a better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy to free and free to
change counselors
if you need to it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial evade is also available
better help once you start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com kid that's
better help and join the over 700 000
people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
there's a special offer for the fire and
the kids listeners you can get attempts
off your first month at betterhelp.com
kid hey kids insurance can be
complicated and that's why
the zebra was created for this exact
reason when you use the zebra.com
insurance finally feels like it's in
black and white no more confusion
just honest rates from real companies
the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site for car and
home insurance they can help you save
money
right now it's so freaking easy go to
the zebra the zebra.com answer a few
quick questions
compare accurate insurance quotes for
free the zebra protects your personal
information all right
there's no hidden fees no surprises
along the way you can secure your
insurance from the zebra.com
uh or over the phone from one of their
licensed insurance
agents over the phone or online i prefer
online myself
with states reopening and people back on
the road the zebra is committed to
making sure
you and your family are covered so how
much money can you save
on car and home insurance well let's
find out visit
the zebra.com fighter that's the zebra
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
fighter for insurance in black and white
all right the zebra dot com slash
fighter
go to current events yeah [ __ ] i just
thought about it like bro it was a full
woman discussion we had bro we men we're
kids
okay so this was submitted by
conlan postama on instagram well a bunch
of people sent this in
wanting you guys to react to lori harvey
and michael b jordan being official
what do you mean two beautiful people
going at it and that's how they made
official that
weird pick i bet they get married i look
like a drink i hope so
dark uh demoted she's so fine i bet they
get married well don't say that
and did was there a caption or is just
like no it's no casting i don't see
anything
no captioning that's just gonna make it
official apparently they saw each
other's family and everything did she
make it official let me see yes yep
she also made it together oh and that's
how people know that this is real
because michael b jordan posted her
michael b jordan doesn't usually post
she doesn't post
shoes she doesn't either one of them
future but besides future no one really
but all her story though not on her not
on her post though on her story she's a
playboy
yeah yeah she never made a post no i
don't know the one where she's uh
come on you know you know no no that's
not doing what he's talking about
right now how do you hear me this is the
original moment when they started
yelling chin
this was the photo
yep michael jordan listen when you're
when your mic will be joined that's
that's what that's
that's the get that's the lane you're in
man i mean that's the lane you're in
if they made it that official they're
getting married no i ain't not i've seen
this all the time
she's she's been with a you know a few
man and she has a catalogue she's not
done michael be joining like the
other [ __ ] that's what i'm saying he's
not he's he's the real dude he's like a
dude's dude like he's a good
like family guy yeah he's a childhood
but we all know that
dude she's been when he's the only one
that's been in g can we all can we all
look
no no no he hasn't been in g i mean
he has been a jesuit well that's like a
normal dude though those other guys yeah
[ __ ] boy
listen thomas the only reason why she's
dating him because he's the currently
reigning
sexiest man alive and they haven't seen
me with a haircut yet
you're telling me you can [ __ ] with
michael b listen you're a good-looking
dude
appreciate that you're great yeah you're
a chrysler 300
he's a royals royce which i have you
ever seen a 300 next to royals royce
you think they look similar you go and
then they pull up you're like
god he said you a chrysler 300 well hold
on
and cr and creed you're the new corvette
those are great
mid engine way to go chevy you ever seen
it next to a real
ferrari 488 with a copied off of you
that fry 48 pull up you
you could get there well here's the
thing yeah you want to get today a
little bit of work of course
yeah you totally could a lot of people
in creed what are you saying they were
saying
and side by side you don't think he
could get there
get where where put us side by side
michael b jordan and malik b all right
now go to my let's go
like go to like uh hold up go to my best
picture what's your best
go all the way down go all the way down
go all the way down go all the way down
and it's coming up right
that's a good one no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no go down go down i want
i want i want there let's go
yeah that's a fair one okay it's a fair
one that's a fair one that's a fair
that's a
good looking picture that's a girl
michael b jordan with his shirt
look at hold on look at this look at
this [ __ ] here look you hit me like my
grandfather with facial hair he looks
like [ __ ] okay thank you look at this
look at this look at him he's in and out
go ahead oh so we're gonna pick his
his worst [ __ ] okay go to his best
pizza we're gonna piss you pick your
best picture we gotta pick his best
hey michael b jordan oh you keep saying
and then he gets out his bank statement
and then he's like come to the crib well
i got
xbox i mean all right well i tried to
defend you malik
oh [ __ ] you're right i just dawned on me
yeah i tried
michael b jordan as killmonger
i'm gaining weight though i'm in the gym
um again you're a good looking dude
he's the best looking dude well he
listen he had work done
let's be honest let's call it that work
done bro his teeth done
and then come on bro we know he's on
steroids right there yeah come on come
on
exactly so let's that's not even fair
like i grew up with four kids that's
steroids
huh oh yeah that's good yeah for creed
for food
anyways listen we all can agree that
nice guys finish last right i think
she'll be
a nice guy he's a nice guy but she's
she's [ __ ] with all these [ __ ] boys
why she's posting it because she found a
real one
and you know he's directing the next
creep i know holla at me bro
you might nope not anymore wait hold on
you out well hold on we don't know that
now he's directing and he's probably
he's directing it yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
bring back my character please
that's dope i need it bring back your
character
no i love you man but never mind all
right sorry
i tried to defend you dawg i appreciate
you i rode with you god bless you
yeah what else you got okay so in
maryland you can officially use rap
lyrics as evidence in a murder trial
it makes sense though so that's all
these feds are catching all these
dumbasses going soundcloud talking about
they murdered people do you think it
should be protected under the guise of
it being an art form no no if you if
you're gonna rap about
if you actually actually killed somebody
and then you put it into lyrics of
course
yeah they're gonna use it how stupid do
you have to be well if the bars are hard
now if it's just all pretend then yeah
you can't but it but if you're
under under investigation for a murder
and then you put a rap song on how you
murdered that person
yeah dumbass yeah we're gonna use that
that's how they got bobby schmurder yeah
but yeah that's how they're getting a
lot of people the feds
the defense is that how they're just
scrolling down instagram and these these
dumb ass are inviting themselves
is that how takashi got no no no no uh
the current guy um it's a black guy i
can't think from new york
uh got cases barred up on racketeering
um
recently he put in his rabbits they're
getting themselves away
why wouldn't they use it so this dude
said i'll couldn't
start with a seat i'll be playing the
block [ __ ] and if you ever play with me
i'll give you a dream a couple shots
snitch you know it's like
hockey pucks the way i dish out this
you're not ready
40 when that [ __ ] going to hit us up
[ __ ]
you see that that sounded awful wait
what is it i don't even know what i'll
be playing the block
[ __ ] ever since you played with me i
give you a dream couple shot snitch
[Applause]
are you i love the commitment i love you
today
you did exactly like it but
it's like hockey pucks away
it's a 40 when that [ __ ] going here
i'm pretty sure he has some good shots
so i don't understand how
this specific lyrics say anything about
him doing anything so bro
a couple of snatches a couple shots he
said he killed someone this is
the situation with this was that he was
arrested on
because he was accused of murder what
ended up happening was while he was in
jail three weeks bef
like three weeks into his sentence
before he had to go to trial and get
sentence and all that
he i believe it was there was somebody
who was gonna snitch on him
and he wrote out these bars he recorded
it over the jail phone
and all of these little details matched
up like the type of gun
the fact that there was somebody that
was going to snitch on him it was kind
of like coming off as a threat
so all these little details just kind of
added up so he was in jail
and he was yeah he recorded it over the
jail phone so it's not like he did this
before it's also stupidity doug also
but those bars have you heard r kelly
through prison no bro it's great oh
world star or no shade room had him
highlighted on there right you listen
yeah i love it from prison he did a song
and it's not
terrible of course it's not gonna be
terrible i love how the shade that's the
first thing that pop-up is a white guy
well you know who that guy is yeah yeah
that's that kelly
but then he wore a shirt to a bar that
said free as [ __ ]
i know i was covered r kelly supporter
how about just put r kelly it's just
it's i mean it's a main story on there
so if you just kept going down where
you're at
it'll pop up keep going because this is
recently right oh yeah yeah
i saw this this weekend did you go to
the website or the uh
the website oh okay it'll be on there
jim keep going
that dumb ass all right i can't believe
a lot of people
nick was busted rhymes he was big oh
shut up
i'm headed towards it she had the
patience
all that money 450 grand she she told
her no nikki
sure it's the main story yeah it'll get
on there
or did i see on world star no it's on
here keep going
kids look at who's here what's her name
ted cash doll
who's that i said cashier cash though
she's from detroit she is a rapper
she pretty good uh well i think
depends on your style a lot of stories
keep going come on how about von miller
oh yeah yeah he tripping
she is she bad she's bad come on with
you
bro man damn cuz she pregnant
damn she bailed oh uh weird
i think it's better we just search our
killing then go through okay
yeah uh keep going though
i really want to find it now but i don't
remember bernie sanders being on my feet
all right yeah typing r kelly yeah what
happened with von miller though
bro so his baby mama she was a stripper
bad
dude listen to a song because it was his
birthday on friday r kelly's birthday
and he has he has insomnia he can't
sleep and when they let him out for two
hours he's so scared because he got
attacked you know
he's scared to leave his uh and they
want to get they want to let him out
what happens here family and friends
won't let him out but they won't do it
so if i click here
but he records music it goes here well
it goes where it goes nowhere they take
it off
they must have go to [ __ ] go to shade
rooms uh instagram yeah they have a
snippet of it on there i bet
and it's three days ago so oh yeah for
von miller though while he's looking it
up
oh so uh girl got pregnant super bad
and then he was doing something like
talking [ __ ] about and she's like you do
not want me to air this out and he kept
talking [ __ ] so she was like okay
dude he was like i hope you get a
miscarriage just like you piece of [ __ ]
like
and then he was like oh all that's fake
and like oh man it doesn't look fake
yeah exactly oh really
and she you got to stand again baddie
let's run let's i want to emphasize how
bad she is dude oh really
i i don't want to bring it up stripper
dog she's a stripper she's an ex
stripper britney that's for this respect
[Laughter]
real quick yeah just yeah damn
uh kelly from prison so she released
he's still creating them beats
she released these text messages or
whatever because he kept that
it makes him look so bad is this one no
that's six months ago
oh yeah damn all this is six months ago
six months you sure it's from positive i
mean
could the recording just be popping up
now brand new hey see uh see if you
type in birthday song because it was his
birthday on friday
he's talking about haters on like uh
coming after him all this [ __ ]
oh there's right here yeah there you go
shut up share song
i don't know if this is gonna be it air
b star r kelly is currently behind bars
awaiting 24th birthday
kelly born of a blessed career telling
what the kelly captioned the clip
thank you
man bro don't you try no i hate when i
click on videos like that bro
just type in shut up that's the name of
the song
why is this so hard to find right
because they probably took it off
nah i mean i seen him from prison to
instagram the beats aren't bad
you know his there he is
[Music]
from prison
that's kind of hard from prison bro
that's horrible prison
dog that's hard bro now he's never
getting out but yeah man
brave if he keeps putting out music like
that i doubt they let him
yeah but still you can't let that
creativity just die now
yeah yeah i heard that yeah yeah can i
see this baddie you were talking about
no hell no
miller's battle hell you don't want to
see it no i don't respect it
stupid x no no you're typing von miller
it'd be the first news
she's so bad oh it's brendan bring some
light into chappelle's monday
it's okay i don't need to see her
her name is morgan denise if anyone
wants to just go to instagram
all right oh my god go to morgan
goodness
that's her there oh that's just well
look it takes me bodies denise
you see uh you know instagram's already
highlighted yep go ahead
god that's right
[Laughter]
oh yeah her name is meg i'm sorry go
ahead i'm sorry do your thing apologize
is this her yeah that's her daughter i
don't see what you guys are seeing
uh click on the second one here i was
about to say you'll see what you'll see
that goddamn love
do you wanna see that heart oh my god
you don't see that that's because you
think a crowbar is sexy
i don't know girl is so bad there's a
fan vote
you should do a fan page yeah they think
this chicken dude if
if you don't think this girl's
attractive he said we should do a fake
vote you look gay man chin what the hell
is wrong with you yo
my style you don't you don't see that i
try curvy chicks though chimp
i'm looking at everything by the way
yeah okay okay face there's
but that's her without any makeup though
that's her without any makeup well no
you got to be pretty without makeup
that that doesn't nothing but i'm like i
don't look her go oh my gosh
would you like taylor swift i do think
she looks a lot better
conversation over thank you have you
seen her
have you seen her without me
conversation oh no i mean
taylor swift i mean they're you know i
never heard no one talk about taylor
swift why would you say
taylor swift cursed
look at this basic white girl
look at that bam that's not real
that's fake it is
now vaughn miller's girl's face was a
little tough the stuff you brought up
well
her body's weird well hold on she's
pretty as [ __ ] oh yeah with her without
makeup is tough but go
and she has freckles yeah yeah me too
y'all know i mean y'all some haters
though
no hold on chin's are here no we're not
hating it's just not my style that's
what i'm saying chin
you understand she's dating a football
player she don't give a [ __ ] about how
she looks right now
go to her single photos chin you with
the single phone
she's like do you think like cardi b is
bad or i think carter be sad yeah
this is all her with javon miller i
don't like you could tell by that
you don't like what nothing what were
you gonna say i wasn't so into cardi b's
face in the beginning but she looks a
lot prettier now it was tough
right i don't think it was time was it
the teeth it was the teeth i liked it
you liked it you liked the teeth [ __ ]
yeah you heard what she said you have
straight teeth
yeah she said she said it was hard to
give head with those
straight teeth oh yeah go go to the head
i like the flaws
that's enough yeah i mean go that green
one real quick and i'm gonna get off
first one
come on oh chin come on chin chin
we're so not on the same page on this
that's the whole you that's
what do you think that's a walking i
think she's gorgeous that's a p right
there man
that's a p chin a p a p look at
i remember i was in houston at 18 years
old and i'm i wasn't supposed to be in
there
hit him and uh we went to v live
and all i was just came back from the
olympics we got a little money my dad
gave me a thousand dollars now back then
that's a lot
right a lot no matter what thousands
okay thousand dollars dog
do you know this girl name her her name
was uh delicious
right enough to get i mean there's one
in every strip club okay we're delicious
but i was she
she was like you want to go to a private
you i'm like hell yeah she took me to a
private room and she did that dance
and i just threw all your money but
about one i was like bro why are you
doing this you fell in love
i was like you don't need this she was
like yeah are you right i just i just
like i need a little bit more cash and
i can get out of here it's like here
just take it yeah standard story you got
hustle
yeah well if i if i just had 500 i could
gas to get me to milwaukee got you come
on
got you well she says she's captain
saboho she got it she wanted to finish
school brandon of course
yeah yeah what school was she going to
she didn't tell me that
exactly well no but no she said she said
she was getting her ba
in a communication yeah that's a lie
that's a lie
that's the easy one to say no it's not
you know how hard communication is how
hard you're pretty for you communicate
you got hustled and that's not a big
deal yeah i wanted to share her name was
delicious
because you had to go she was sober you
have a good time i had a great time
exactly where was this
girl mixed girl she's like black girl
yeah i'm talking about what's better
than houston
20 listen i know it was like we were
talking for like six songs and you know
they charged by the song yeah yeah yeah
i was like
you thought you had a connection yeah
what do you mean you know he's stupid
right
that's what that's that's their agenda
101 make sure the connection
he was eight you become you're a regular
yeah she got all thousands right every
penny yeah
the whole thousand and we all walked
back and then professional
[ __ ] i got her number yeah i got a
number we take whatever yeah i got
hanging out after that
no never you never did i was in the same
predicament that was when i didn't have
her number when i had it that's
basically what you're saying yeah
i didn't see her afterwards you didn't
see her oh i texted her a little bit i'm
unless i'm the same thank you i thought
love too yeah
but at least i know what's going on but
i was 18. i didn't know
i know she got you it happens did you
ever like have
experience with that no i mean the chick
brought me up it was but
this was a whorehouse can i say that
[Applause]
i went to a whorehouse robbed yeah
that's all my money so dude can't bang
it on the door get out
yeah like what were you in there for a
hot second
i was in there for five minutes and he
said get out yeah cause
because okay so it was so weird was this
thing this is back home in arizona
so it outside it looked like these were
these were chappelle two on fourteen
days
no this one that was two thousand um six
oh oh oh six yeah i was 19. oh six in a
whorehouse mm-hmm okay cause
i was moving to texas and my buddy was
like hey man you know
let's go out your last night in town
let's go to the street club great guy
and i was like all right
[ __ ] yeah let's go to the strip club
yeah and we wrote we were driving around
for a long time trying to find one
yeah go to this spot it's a lot it was
like in an industrial area
you know it was like all weird and then
we go in
and uh there was rooms you know yeah and
then uh
like strip like private rooms right yeah
it was rooms like it was like i was like
why the [ __ ] is the room
and they were like uh you go to the room
to the right you go to the room to the
left are you kidding
me pick out the girl huh yeah a group of
girls came in
and you were like seven of them walked
in like and they literally like choose
one of us
and i was like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah it takes so long like rush hour too
yeah
i thought it took you way too long to
put way too long so i choose one you
know
and white girl black girl uh there's
only white girls
arizona makes sense uh in the horizon
do you remember her name what the [ __ ]
no was it cinnamon or something
like no i can't remember okay but uh i
just know i was like
she was like okay so what do you want to
do i was like listen i'm only going to
stay here if my buddy's going to stay
here it's just like okay let me
i'll be right back and then she goes she
goes she comes she leaves and it comes
back in and goes
oh your buddy's going to stay and i was
like oh okay well she probably
just made that up exactly because they
never [ __ ] asked him anything
no she went outside like yeah yeah yeah
so we got one we got a lot she was like
i can't remember how much she said they
charged for the full service but i was
like listen i only got like 50 bucks
because i won't try to
well you know spend anything get your bj
i guess out there
no no no no no no no no not even a hell
of a let me tell you so
they look at you she no no yeah she just
danced in front of me
for 50. yeah yeah for uh five minutes
but here's the thing
i'm pulling out my money yeah right and
she snatches it
she just snatched my money all of it bro
and i was so terrified i was so young
that i just let her do it because 19.
yeah and then she she runs out
right all right and i'm sitting there
and i'm sitting here somebody's flopping
everywhere no no this is before she even
started
she because she takes my money and takes
it out there right she comes back in
dances from me five minutes and then
then dude knocks on the door
get out and i was like okay so i'm
sitting in the lobby waiting on my homie
and i'm like man why the [ __ ] is he
taking so long what the [ __ ] is he doing
this whole comes out
with his collar popped shoes off
he's been there right yeah i was like
bro you think you stumbled upon yeah
i was like what'd you do so he paid i
think it was like 450 bucks
that's expensive to jerk himself off in
front of the girl
in front of the girl but like what a
great deal for you well he got he was
like he goes out
so i negotiated for her to let me like
finger
at the same time so he paid for him for
that poor house cooch
this is fingers [ __ ] yeah it's still 450
and you're
jacking on sounds like because he had to
put uh he said that
he had to put a towel over him oh yeah
he can't be just [ __ ] yeah they won't
let him like have like that they'll be
busted
yeah he said he said it was taking
him forever like i'm pretty sure she
should have helped him out at least
she was just she was naked that was all
she heard so like his thing was like
he paid for a service of he gets the
jack off
while she just stands there's a terrible
deal
no they were busted but i'll tell you it
was in an industrial area it was like
all
right you know your friend been there a
bunch of times
why was his shoes off in his collar i
don't know why because he was naked
oh he jacked off naked yeah yeah
you got hustle bro my homies my homie is
a radical [ __ ]
i want to say his name yeah i won't say
his name come to the show
uh no he didn't come to sean phoenix i
won't say his name but man
he's ready to tell you oh are you a
tribute i feel like you get real tense
in the strip club too no i just love it
back in the day though
when i had your tongue pierced
a little after the tongue like that
cheetahs i used to love cheetahs all
right out here no no no in las vegas oh
yeah yeah so
whenever we went to vegas we would go to
strip clubs and it was and then sapphire
too
oh yeah did you do the rhino did you do
uh no
you know there's like girls and guys at
the spear miranda right no i didn't know
what do you mean there's like these
girls can go somewhere about the same
guys
like there's like two different levels
oh no really i ain't going to the galaxy
yeah yeah i don't know
that sounds real good
did you guys ever hook up inside a strip
club no i just got hurt did you
i did yeah like but not actual sex sex
but
pretty much everything else we had a
little private little thing with
curtains
and my friends were there with their
strippers to the boom boom room yeah so
they were
i was all making out and doing stuff how
much did you pay for that i don't
remember my buddy paid for it
hail really yeah have you been no never
no there hasn't been an occurrence where
i'd ever go
some chicks like it some girls do like
it i'm sure i'd have fun i just
never had them they'd be all over you
really yeah girls
you girls like other people they love it
yeah they love when the guys come with
girls
yeah dude how are you from what i hear
no have you seen that uh rapper uh blue
face have you seen his instagram bro did
you see the hell
yes did you just did you have you seen
it yeah
you seen this well oh my god hold tight
listen no no no i do your favorite
t-bird [ __ ] t
firebird hold on i'm gonna see if this
bro instagram
yeah like they be hold on t5 they're
nude yeah
t firebird let me see it's always at his
house yes
it's at his house or whatever something
like that this is a young man with money
didn't he
have like a reality show on his only
fans with him oh yeah
the bad girls club yeah i mean i
remember watching one only fans when
he's spilling milk on these
strippers yeah to work into the milk
i'm about to show you that everyone was
looking for this one stripper
i know oh the one that was like yeah
yeah i was saying t5 bird or something
like that
damn i didn't know you knew about his
instagram like bro
that shit's on world star oh yeah it's
always on yeah that [ __ ] was
hold on that [ __ ] was popping yeah
i was blown away at what he was like
showing on there yeah he's living life
man i don't know this is the girl right
here that everyone was trying to find
that girl yes yes everyone was trying to
find oh why would you trying to find her
bro she was going crazy you didn't see
what she was doing
oh she was going in don't let me try to
she's getting wild yes
it's like it's usually in his stories
because
yeah he'll get banned oh here it is
right here nobody firebird
firebird pimp firebird that's the girl
firebird pimp maybe she got like some
stuff
firebird pimp that's all right here look
did she post anything yeah that's her
though okay
go to our story at least she looks crazy
yeah i don't see it there either
halloween no time i don't know go up go
out
her uh story said uh that little circle
said bag season
you know what that means what's back
season about to find out i saw a lot of
money go out work tonight or chill
how long this video lives in my head
that's her there but yeah she's a
stripper she's a stripper
but she's wild i'm wild what do you want
to look for
just keep going through a story let's
keep going through our story but look at
the back season look at the back season
right there
to the far left you see it that makes
sense
here we go let's see yeah what's she
doing it's her with bags of money okay
wait wait that's bags
what's she doing with it hold on wait
all right look at that yeah
damn girls just be getting wild they
look bro they loved it
this pandemic man is that blue face
story no
all right she's all right looking yeah
she was going crazy you understand
that everyone was trying to find her
damn how'd you find her
that's her there let me see nah that's
not her i think i heard she on the
podcast is there
nobody else there it's a pandemic it's a
pandemic that's her right there here we
go
is that blue face i don't know no
no that's like it's a video whoa god
damn
what are they she's hitting her
scissoring is that what they call that
yeah i think so
are they pounding it though brendan yeah
i'm not into that
she's all right she looks a little
little hood wrap for me man
a little ratchet right yeah yeah well i
don't know she's making bank though
she's that's the strippers i mean what
do you mean
well how are you see better looking
strippers than that but you i want them
nasty i don't i don't
it's cute women all day now if you just
gonna do all right you're right all
right i'm not mad at her yeah yeah
that's true
she should be hanging on some ugly dudes
man she's stripping so hard her eyelash
falling off you see that
god damn she in la is she now she all
here this is
this is a day ago by the way
all right that's enough okay not a
[ __ ] given with covid either no this
is 11 hours ago
i'm telling you if you see blue blue
faces instagram stories they're like
yeah insane yeah yeah he's living bro
living life
all right what else you got jen um
i know you got the uh the princess pizza
on yeah
yeah that's a sad one you want to take i
sent this to you guys princess pizza
they're not shutting down they're just
under different management yeah so after
the
uh racist statements were resurfaced
with both the owners which is a father
and son
duo they actually stepped down i believe
it was
saturday they announced on instagram
that day-to-day management would no
longer be taken over by them
it would be taken over by somebody else
email talking [ __ ] like when i looked at
the race comments a lot
i think the photo was a female but then
the account belonged to the owner
so it could have been like his wife or
yeah there's a lot of uh complaints of
the customer service
and the racist stuff was more towards uh
asians right like they called like one
lady a yellow dog
a yellow dog a mongol a mutt yeah yeah
listen that pizza is so good every time
if every time i went in there they
called me a cracker and spit on my face
i'd be cool
j j goes oh yeah i don't care they can
spit in my face and call me white devil
food is delicious he goes uh i called
you a mutt which means
coward i called you a yellow dog which
means coward i called you a mongrel
which is what you are
you aren't there [ __ ] you're on the
camera you [ __ ] fool
what were they thinking who's that lady
well that's the that's the avatar that's
the avatar i don't know
who the woman is i assume that it was
like maybe his wife
because maybe she's the one who set up
the yelp account at one point it's like
if i see you tell me where you're at
i'll [ __ ] you up i'll break your job
yeah he made fun of a lot of the uh
protesters too
he posted a joke on his instagram story
saying like why did the
uh protester cross the street to get ran
over and he was talking about black
lives matter
so it was it was a lot of different [ __ ]
that was coming out not
fantastic pizza but uh
i'm already thinking fellas they're cool
out here in california
i mean i don't know they wouldn't be
nice to me it's very
interesting though because uh last
sunday not yesterday but
the prior week when i got back from west
palm beach my sister and i went to go
get
uh prince street pizza we went got a
couple slices and they got our order
wrong so i went back
and told them like hey you guys are
missing this and gave us this and said
this
the guy said oh i'm so sorry for the
inconvenience here take a whole
pepperoni pizza for free
and me taking i was like oh they're so
nice this is so cool we got back in the
car
i posted about it that night and
somebody damned me was like
they're racist and send me all this [ __ ]
and i was in my head i was like
i wonder if this was a pr movie yeah i
know like they saw an asian girl like oh
thank you
maybe we got to do this but that's a
[ __ ] it's all time
yeah but they're not closing they're
just changing management
yeah the father and son are still owners
of the pizza shop so it's one of those
things where
if you still buy from them you're still
putting money in their pockets but
they're not in charge of the day-to-day
management
they got a lot of heat on social media
too because they were uh
taking down a lot of comments about
people saying that they were racist and
then people called them out on that they
had to make a statement saying that they
wouldn't delete stuff on the instagram
right under their the company profile
it's terrible
under the company yeah like be better
being racist if y'all
they doubled down on a lot of the stuff
that they said because there was some
backlash when
it first started and then they would
double down on it
and that kind of went away but now all
these things are resurfacing
during this time it's like it's just a
shame to see man
damn so we can't get that pizza no more
let's not get crazy
let's not take this out of time it's
still delicious
i'll still buy it you know it's like
you know yeah i don't support what you
don't you won't
oh i'm bringing dollar here yeah
yeah no not black owned dollars
did you eat the cactus the racism was
mainly towards asians
ah see it's one of those things like
they do have delicious pizza and i do
love pizza but i don't think i like
pizza enough to
go buy it anymore if i'm being honest
you're out i'm out yeah
i looked at it and it just sounds like
something like the whole thing i was
like where's the actual real real racism
saying yellow dog that was like the
closest thing i i saw
yeah but then i did look up yelled at
yellow doesn't mean coward too you know
you know what you yell
you yellow belly whatever yeah so i mean
i don't know okay i don't i don't have
too much feelings either way yeah yeah
i don't think i have enough feelings
where i i won't eat their pizza anymore
yeah because you don't have a dog in a
fight
i mean a little bit i like i mean i'm
the only white person
that i employ everyone else is asian or
black that
are you doing so i don't i definitely
don't [ __ ] with racism
i think if it was there if someone
bought it i'd eat it but i want to go
out of my way to get it it seems like
yeah that's what i was trying to say
it's weird
with chin because they're italian right
so it's like yellow
he's like i'm calling you a coward i'm
not saying yellow because you're skin
that's why you
just business customer service is
terrible but
listen i listen to breakfast club and
charlemagne talk [ __ ] about white people
every [ __ ] day
yeah you should do something yeah but
you still like his
i get his angle but yeah calling white
people white isis or vanilla ices
that's not right either no it's like
dude it's getting old man like
at some point you got to stop yeah like
a lot of white people gave him a lot of
breaks
so not all white people are racist or
bad people
i get sick of that i'm not going to stop
listening to charlemagne but that's his
perspective
for those italians it's like is it
racist
if i went to it and they were dropping
the n word and saying that
then i'm i all right i can't i can't
defend that
but as a small business owner in black
lives and
did their new york uh establishment get
raided or looted
and that's their perspective i get it
man if you don't have if you can't do
business because
the protest something and they're
probably pretty upset i don't know if
it's a racist thing more towards a
protest i think it was
angry you think it's a great issue but
again they're not dropping n bombs or
things
they said saying derogatory terms
towards asians if it's [ __ ] or slander
that's different yeah then
there were certain terms in there that i
didn't even know was like some old
school
challenge it's like yeah that's what i'm
saying it sounds like only just like oh
yeah
mutt but i guess but it doesn't like if
they're
like biracial like black and white
people not necessarily i didn't even
i didn't even think that i thought mutt
was just like oh you're just calling
someone
a dog but if again if they would have
went blatant racist
n words [ __ ] all that [ __ ] i'm out man
yeah but this
is like all right just dumb customer
service yeah
okay that's fair i like that yeah where
you pimp yeah but but what the
mongrel yeah which is another thing
that's not a word for
and but it's the lady wrote the dog of
no definable type of breed so it's just
absolutely
like your dog yeah that's what i said
that's
is social media making it worse he's
like whoa what the f i'm not saying that
it's a yellow dog
i'm sure that's the key word that made
them look racist cause they use yellow
yellow yeah
yellow dog i'm running into this cancer
culture i'm still buying their pizza
makes sense all right
next one discuss that but all right so
chappelle mentioned
the the white dude climbing thing and
fell down so i followed jamie foxx and
jamie foxx posted the actual video
there i knew i wasn't crazy this one
yeah what'd he say hold on let me put
the beast card
[Music]
that's hilarious it's so good did you
know the uh
the cops that ate it the uh people that
go in the capital they're going to
prison as well did y'all know that
they've arrested so many people yeah
i also found out that apparently people
trying to leave like some people were
identified during that riot
some people weren't able to get on a
plane and go back home because they were
put on to no flight
no flight and they didn't know until
they got to the airport okay yeah
you know one of the guys committed
suicide too really one of the the
people in charge of keeping the people
out committed suicide it's a cop yeah
security for years
like a dad committed suicide oh wow
so that's like six or some people have
died so far it's dark
yep yeah uh what do you think of this
trump being banned on all social media
apps
major ones it's kind of crazy right
from facebook i think facebook too yeah
oh yeah so so facebook owns instagram oh
instagram
you get banned from one you can get oh i
didn't know
here's where this gets dicey whether
you're republican democrat
if you're going to take away someone's
freedom of speech based off
you don't like their opinions where does
it stop so where
where is this going to stop now now now
we're becoming like a little bit like
north korea
where the so now it's a dignity now
these far
liberal owners of social media uh
twitter
and facebook and youtube now they're
gonna dictate what you
put out yeah what you said that's not
that's not the way america's supposed to
work
it's not that i'm advocating for any of
this but isn't there an argument that
they are all
privately owned businesses because the
way somebody explained it to me
where they said imagine that all these
private
companies like instagram uh facebook
they are
that christian bakery who didn't want to
make a gay wedding cake
and trump is that gay do they have the
right to turn him away until you go get
your cake somewhere else
or do they have to make it even though
it goes against their morals if it's a
privately owned business it's tough
because social media right so it's world
like even though they're a private
company their numbers
say it's almost like they're the media
now like that's what a lot of people
are doing that's where everyone gets
their media
so business-wise they might be a private
company but
usage-wise they're worldwide they're
international right so
the problem is when when these they're
you know they're super
liberal so if they don't like a message
that it's going out they dictate what we
see and what we don't
you just can't have that man you just
can't you just can't have whether you
agree with a knight you can't have that
yeah it's because where's it gonna stop
so the next
republican candidate if they don't like
they're going to take that out
or for instance with corona stuff if you
didn't agree with what
their doctor said they got rid of it we
can't have that man
also we're turning into north korea like
you're turning and when they falsely
like when someone gets falsely accused
of something on
a social media outlet they don't take
that they don't take it down yeah they
just leave it up
how about how about they ban trump but
then find
mike pence and kill him didn't get
banned
it's terrible they they could pick and
choose all this that's not it's not safe
it's not that's not serious it's not
good now i don't agree with what trump
did
i don't agree with any facet but you
can't you're gonna ban him from having a
voice
that's the president united states they
banned them or they just dude
they banned him so he can't enter the
and if and if
he went on someone else's account and
tried using theirs they banned that
account
so he can't get any message out yeah
been at alex jones didn't they yeah
he did but it is this is such a crazy
move i can't believe it happened
now see but i i think you can take down
him condoning violence and encouraging
that riot you can take down that tweet
or that post
but to not give him a voice and suspend
for a little while even i'm down with
that
but to take him off it's like a
permanent it's a permanent suspension
yeah you're going down
yeah because then then now let's say
americans are like okay that's cool
then where's it stop man where's it
gonna stop
you're going down such a slippery road
man
did they say he provoked violence
yeah but even if you look go get them on
that you know
yeah or something like if that's what it
was but yeah it's a ban i don't know
yeah i feel weird about like the whole
banning
for anyone you know what i mean it's
just i don't know it's just not a myth
it's not what we do in america
just not what we do we're not russia
we're not north korea
we're not china you know because then
then it's like then they can dictate
any anything after that dude
everything's like yeah like
it just gets weird like even well then
if you try to say something well then
you turn to cnn where there's
one agenda it's only you that you only
have this angle
and they're just feeding you yeah
pushing one one agenda
yeah that makes sense let the people
decide yeah
what you say like suspend you agree with
i don't i don't even like that you know
but i mean if you're going to do
something don't go as far as just take
this
if you think it's encouraged violence
you can take the tweet yeah and
like even when corona hit when certain
doctors came out like or like dr drew or
someone was like
it's not as deadly as we think this they
would pull that down because they didn't
agree with their agenda
yeah he can't have that who was the
author who whose book got taken down he
was talking about kova
i think rogan had him on i don't know
you know
it's just a slippery slope man it's just
so un-american whether you agree with it
or not it's not good
well what you think what else you got oh
no you said no no just just digesting
this whole conversation
okay i like your words appreciation
because because imagine if the if the
owners of zuckerberg and the other
dumbass you're on twitter jack
jack jack dorsey i think imagine if they
were far right and they were for
trump and they banned all the black
lives matter stuff or any or biting or
anyone who said it could be a chaos it
would be chaotic
outrage yeah that's why no but then
we're just all cool with this site
because we just some people don't
you have to be in the middle of it you
can't just dictate oh we don't like what
he's saying we're going to ban him from
the
app what social media
is it's our newsletter yeah
even though i'm like uh we get every
we're always on our phones like apple
news everything is literally on your
phone so when you banned them
i'm asking we'll say female chrome let's
say let's say zuckerberg didn't believe
and thought chronos fake
and banned all the data we have on
corona
[Music]
this is no different this is zero
different
it's such a slippery road man it's such
a slippery road
move it on yes all right the next one
this kind of sucks he's uh dr dre still
in the
icu i still don't know why he had these
aneurysms that's terrible
man yeah
okay you know what i know hopefully he
gets over it you know remember that girl
that we were talking about
last episode the one that attacked that
14 year old boy oh
yeah so apparently she had two different
dui
suspicions or whatever uh arrests
before and then she does seem like she
has like
some sort of mental issue she says gang
members are killing
people right now yeah and you want to
arrest a girl so she's kind of like
she's
you know whatever resisting arrest
pretty badly and then
the remember that daddy had that she
wore yeah the lawyer said
she she should not wear that hat on tv
and then she was like no i want to wear
it
it's my thing so she feels like she has
like some mental disability
because it's not going to look good to
wear that daddy hat obviously right
yeah she might just be a dumbass yeah or
just i think she's just stupid and
doesn't
realize what's going on a lot of people
give her too much credit
just an idiot damn
take that hat off she asked specifically
to take that hat off before the
interview that was her lawyer that said
that
yeah she was like yeah she ain't
listening to her lawyer yeah she's just
what's she saying you're my lawyer
you're not my mama you know so she said
that
oh i can envision that that's basically
what she's saying she's just a dumbass
yeah yeah but she's not white so wait
everyone's like oh she's a karen she's
she's not white
it's nuts man we're going down a scary
road i'm scared about the whole
social media thing with trump like his
who all the supporters are going to be
like freaking out like crazy yeah
they're going crazy yeah so i think some
something bad's gonna happen you're
talking about the 70 million people that
voted for i think it's
70 million i heard people are gonna
start protesting out of the san
francisco twitter building now
i'm all for that i don't want violence i
definitely don't in
encourage violence i'm pretty sure
there's gonna be a lot of violence i
don't think so we've seen at the capitol
britain
different animal because you got to
realize that the capital would
was also inside like trump let the fbi
told them that something was going to go
on they had knowledge that something was
going on
trump encouraged that at facebook you
don't think of course they're going to
know you're going to have armed guards
out there they're not going to let them
attack [ __ ] facebook have you ever
been a facebook campus
it's probably tougher to get into than
[ __ ] the capital it's there's a huge
per
perimeter around it it's a campus man
yeah i mean
they're expecting and mike and
zuckerberg has more money than god
those people aren't going to be able to
roll in there and take over trump's
listen and they're super liberal they're
not gonna that ain't gonna happen
i feel like most people in silicon
valley are also working from home
so like if you're protesting you're
protesting an empty building right now
yeah probably yeah
all right can you go back to that video
she said uh game game
uh members are killing people right now
you don't watch the whole it's just
i'll sum it up for you this is stupid
all she's saying is you're arresting me
i've done nothing
there's gang members killing people
there's actually people that are like
real murderers
criminals yeah and what did she do do
you watch oh do you
hear her and her mom were in the car
kind of argument yeah she's in there and
she was kind of drunk yeah
and she's 22. yep yeah okay
trash uh just one more this thing went
viral
it's a tick talker talking about a ghost
kitchen so she's a door dash person
so she has to pick up foods from a
location and bring it to the people
right
so this is what she showed
i can't play the music so give me a sec
okay just read
oh they're going under different names
yeah so that's actually chuck e cheese
mr beast burger is from buca di beppo
ice cream shop from 7-eleven wow wait i
don't
wait wait dude again what is this these
businesses are pretending to be
these local businesses because people
are trying to support local business
make sure that those restaurants
still stay alive during this time but
they're it's actually like you're
ordering from chuck e cheese not this
like local pizza shop
yeah so she says ghost restaurants yeah
yeah like ghost kitchens go sketch
yeah let's do it actually find out his
ghost restaurant all right play it again
one more time okay so he can get it
chappelle so he can get i got it
so it's just wings not really anything
it looks like a local place but it's
chili's yeah
and pasquale's pizza and wings looks
like local but it's a chuck e cheese
chicken cheese pizza is pretty good
though that's right this is trash bappo
all right i feel like it is delicious
yup that's it damn all right ghost
kitchen
it's always it bugs me that's that's a
risk when you go
with door dash or uber eats anything
cause you don't know if the guy eating
your fries you don't know and it's cold
like it's just
it's just a risk all the way around but
shout out well or
order food online 100 food online it's a
gamble yeah it is a good
come pretty safe now but yeah staples
the restaurants staple them so you can't
get into them anymore
you get chick-fil-a there's stickers all
over it where if they break the stairs
you know if someone's
oh i've had a few times before they were
doing that with my fries came half empty
i'm like god damn
[Laughter]
all right
a long drive up here all right man this
cruise in san marcos texas
tickets are almost sold out only the big
tables are open but i think they're
going to break those up so you don't
have to go in a group of 10.
uh limited capacity limited seats i only
get comps
uh january 29th through the 30th two
shows uh friday two show saturday
january 29th 30th of this [ __ ] month
san marcos texas get your tickets now
t-fat
k-z dot-com get em kids
uh all think boy gear thick boy hoodies
hats
fit girl gear go to thickboy.com that's
it we'll see you guys wednesday